We've seen how to simplify radicals, so now let's try adding and subtracting
them. We can use our knowledge of what we learned before to help us add
radicals together. For example, to add polynomials together, we just added the
like terms of x squared and x squared. We have three of these things called x
squared, and two of these things called x squared. So if we add them all
together, we'll have 5 of these things that we call x squared. In a similar
way, we added 3 7ths and 2 7ths to equal 5 7ths. And most recently, we learned
how to add rational expressions. If our denominators were alike, then we could
add the numerators to get 5 divided by x plus 1. So based on what you know
before, what do you think would be the sum of these two expressions?